yo it's dj head i'm here at the bootleg
kf podcast just crazy [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying shout out to white
people west coast
yo it's the bootleg head podcast oh my
god
ladies and gentlemen my good friend my
brother my my
ex-co-host yeah dj head
west coast west coast i know the people
was waiting for that you know what i'm
saying
west coast is in the building yeah this
is interesting
it is this is so interesting i just want
to say
uh just for the record i want to start
off by saying this
on record i've said this on the radio
yeah but i've never
i've never said it in your presence
because we haven't really seen each
other
the way you handled i heart letting you
go
yeah was [ __ ] incredible like i think
and i said i don't know if you have you
heard or heard or have anybody told you
when i was on the air
when i went on the air the day after day
after you left i heart
i went on the air at 7 00 p.m sharp
and i said the way boule kev has handled
this situation
is bar none and moving forward nobody
can tell me anything about bootleg kev
yeah man i think you know you and i
would have these talks
off all the time i mean all the [ __ ]
time
and you know what another thing too
people are like hey didn't you know
i'm like bro you know how many times
they hit me it was like me and you got
the same kind of call we thought you
missed doc's call and we thought we were
both
done i thought i was known but this is
the thing people was like man did you
get a heads up i said bro you know how
many times i've been told like i'm a
fire kev you better talk to him you know
what i'm saying like
yeah i think i think well what's crazy
is i got resigned
in april during the pandemic they
resigned me for three years
and that don't mean [ __ ] right no so
then
i got that call in december and then i
called you yeah
and then while i was talking to you doc
was calling you yeah and then you
clicked over and you said
you said oh yeah it's over bro yeah that
was a laugh
you called me back like hey i'm good
over here why don't you talk about it
right before
right before i click over to get the
doomsday call kev is like yo it's over
bro
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] yeah i mean look it for me
you know i mean
i was i was already kind of
over doing radio the traditional way the
way that we were doing it yes
and it's probably safe to say that had
been the case for a while yeah
so for me i looked at uh getting let go
by iheart and real 923 uh first of all
shout out to doc winner because
i know that it wasn't i mean he you know
it wasn't like he was like yo you're
fired
we're not [ __ ] with you yo we got
we're letting go of some people because
of the budgets this pandemic pandemic
yeah you know i got paid on my severance
so
and again like for me it was more
it cleared my my time it cleared my
clear you know what what i realized
during the pandemic when you and i were
doing our show from zoom
how much other [ __ ] i could be doing if
i had more flexibility to not be
physically at the radio station every
day
you know i was busting plays moving
around i was in mexico on zoom with you
doing the show it was like yo this is
kind of fire this pandemic [ __ ] kind of
lit
but it but it also it also just kind of
made me realize like
man i want to you know i'd already been
to tooling with the idea of
doing a syndicated show i launched the
podcast
during the pandemic in june and it just
kind of like
me getting let go was amazing i'm not i
i at zero like not a single time
did i ever feel some type of way no
because people get fired and they get
all [ __ ] mad and it's like ego [ __ ] i
literally was like i got let go and my
girl started crying
and i was like why are you crying we're
about to turn the [ __ ] up
like this is great yeah you know like i
get i get to get paid until
for the next [ __ ] four months and now
i can just double down on
what i was gonna try to do anyway yeah
so yeah
you know and i think like for anybody
who's watching this like but i think
no i was gonna say like just know like
if you're in radio
or you're anywhere like it's not
in your best interest if someone lets
you go because of
financial purposes if it's not personal
don't make it personal
it should never be personal yeah you
always say that all the time
we've seen a lot of people leave that
current radio station
and they take things personal and then
guess what happens you burn a bridge
yeah i don't i don't believe in taking
anything personal three three rules i
live by
all the time be undeniable bring value
don't take [ __ ] personal
but that's all that aside though even
even even though you didn't take it
personal and you'd like
i'm about to turn you look at this
opportunity yeah the way you
handled it though was [ __ ] fire
like i don't know i don't know that that
that doesn't happen
a lot right especially like it's like
hey no like go do your [ __ ]
yeah for me it was like i'm just like i
talk with i talk with doc i talk with ao
and i
i was like yo it's it's all good like
it's all good
well you know i released my statement
and i'm obviously rooting for you and
chuck
i love you guys you know you guys
this is meant to be homegrown radio
needs to be on
every night in l.a this is something you
guys have worked forever for
and i'm like yo that this is great
everyone wins here
i feel like i'm winning you know a lot
of people from the outside looking to
probably
kill god i don't give a [ __ ] i don't
care what other people think and then
you guys get to
have your shot at nights together yeah
you guys are you know been friends
forever
long everyone won yeah literally
everybody won and you and i's
relationship hasn't been affected
like you and i we know if you know you
know me and head are locked in with each
other we could not talk for two or three
weeks a month and like as soon as we
talk we know what's up
you know there's never been any sort of
weird energy between me and head
i remember somebody said somebody said
on twitter they was like man
i want you guys once you go on kev's
podcast and then
and then you just play me the thing he
was some guy was like why don't you go
on kev's podcast i was like
i probably will eventually i thought it
made sense later like yeah i'll play
we had some guy from ireland shout out
to ireland man yeah check this out
yo what's going on man long time no chat
long time ago hope all is well and all
the farm alone as well
and we just want to say big ups to be
like cap shows [ __ ] sick i
really really enjoyed the twister
episode and would love to see
head on at some point because i just
think you guys had such an incredible
chemistry
and i think that'd be a dope episode and
better get stuck in on the soldier boy
episode but yeah can't wait for more and
would love to see you head on
have a absolute smashing day my man god
hey what's his name
uh shout out to uh martin ocean martin
ocean in ireland
salute to you bro here we are in ireland
i believe
here we are god damn it yeah so i think
like you know whenever something like
this happens
you know and you know it's crazy we've
never talked about this publicly before
nah nah i mean you talked on the phone
about it a bunch
yeah i mean uh but yeah i think whenever
something like this happens like it's
always like
we're just used to people being weirdos
i'm used to for shobey i'm blood listen
and it's like dude like there's never
been no ego type of [ __ ] involved
between us
and when this [ __ ] happened it was like
yo dope like yo
chuck's on the night show he deserves to
get a shot on the night show you guys
this is amazing and i get to do what i
wanted to do anyway yeah
and be mobile and be flat and flexible
and you know and so
it's a win-win and so i'm definitely i'm
happy i'm glad you guys are killing it i
saw you i
got the billboards going and yeah i just
talked to amen i heard y'all smashing up
them leakers over there you know what
i'm saying
i don't i don't know nothing about none
of that
i i know that i know that our ratings
are are good they're solid yeah
so you know congratulations but yeah i
think um you know
that was again one of the main things yo
everything good were you in head yeah
what do you mean well people always
think that like people always look at
like how
i guess what it you know what it is is
people so used to people being weird
that they're not used to authenticity
right and so authenticity is weird to
people now because
it's not it's it's not normal to be that
way yeah and i think too there's been uh
recent radio
situations that publicly were ugly
yeah you know you think back shout out
to our guy big boy like when he left
power it wasn't
it wasn't pretty it wasn't pretty you
know what i mean like there's been
situations where it's like
shout out to our guy cruz who'll be
he'll be radio banging on that twitter
show yeah but you know i get it like for
for i get both of their situations
because what happened to them was
extremely personal yeah it's super
personal for me it was never perfect
i've never been a part of that for me
either i'm like dude like
what am i going to get mad like i'm
chilling and they like
like i wasn't like making money hand
over fist over there you know i mean
so yeah it's good to have you uh have
you on the show and uh
so how's uh how is everything in dj head
world been
man i think honestly it's been a
blessing i've had a chance to you know
what's crazy
is in the this is and this is i don't
think i've ever said this
before publicly either but i remember
thinking one time during the pandemic
when he was doing our show right and
this is like
right when george floyd happened yeah
and the whole [ __ ]
and so and i remember having a selfish
moment because i was thinking like damn
i remember getting one and again i mean
you would always talk about it in the
studio like and the reason we wanted to
get into radio is to do dope interviews
create dope content yeah create dope
hip-hop moments right whatever
and i remember the fun part of it
so i remember coming up here and this is
when mustard cracked off 2012 to 2014.
it was just la was the sound and woo
right and that was the reason why i want
to do it and not get
and then and the selfishness in me he
was like damn but i get race riots
police brutality
donald trump oh yeah that was like are
you gonna lie man being on the air
during that time the pandemic on zoom
was very rough the pandemic coven 19.
we're trying to do like an actual show
over zoom about all this
wild ass [ __ ] like la's on fire bro
and it's like i mean riots across the
country
no i'm sorry across the world right yeah
the way we had to do the show was
probably my least
favorite part of my radio career not
that we had to talk about that stuff but
just the fact that we had to do it from
our house
and try to make it sound as like it was
that [ __ ] sucked
and so i remember thinking to myself
like damn how'd i get dealt with this
hand
as i want to be in the other in other
you know like
having fun and [ __ ] but then i started
thinking about it oh it's not about me
and so once i understood it's not about
me everything since then has been a
blessing like i look at
my my life now is a complete blessing
everything that i'm doing
uh i know what's going on with the
[ __ ] netflix show
rhythm and flow i know that the uh
they've announced season two is gonna
happen and then obviously the pandemic
struck
rhythm and flow season two uh i don't
have any
official updates i do know that you can
go on the website
um can you submit your demo i believe
they are still accepting uh
um what do you call it auditions
obviously the pandemic got in the way of
that happening sooner
yeah i remember that we were we were
supposed to do something
and then obviously the cover 19 shut
everything down it was everything was
shut down the marvel cinematic universe
was shut down nothing stops that
so if it was able to stop the nba in the
marvel cinematic universe
everybody else got to fend for
themselves yeah that's crazy did you
watch uh one division of course i've
been caught up on everything
what do you think of one division i
thought one division was good
i just i barely but it was slow i barely
just started watching it and i barely
just got to episode
five so it started picking up a little
bit yeah cause i'm like man
what's going on i'm like what the [ __ ]
when you're watching it if you're not if
you're not
in in you kind of like what the [ __ ] is
going on
but then it starts to like peel back and
peel back and then later on
it gets good but it's slow it's a slow
burn it's not as good
falcon in the winter soldier fighting is
fire i got to tap
in that [ __ ] is fire and they just
announced
black panther yes sir july 8th 20th oh
my god
shout out to ryan coogler shout out to
archie who do we think is gonna uh
i have my own theories we were talking
they should just
give it up to michael b jordan loki i
have been i've heard rumors this is not
official and i haven't heard this many
insiders
this is youtube theory that michael b
jordan will be coming back
and i the theory is that he's going to
take on the mantle or sure he is which
is
because he was like a very endearing
loving like bad guy
people [ __ ] with even at the end
jordan yeah he's a by the way michael b
jordan the most overrated actor
that [ __ ] can is not a good
actor he's he's
he's a nice looking guy to look at he
plays great characters
but he is not a great it's hard for me
to watch michael jordan to act i
i i'm not even gonna lie really i don't
think he's a great actor he's not bad
he's not bad he's not good
i didn't say that i'm saying he's not
bad at all he's kind of like uh
nah you know what you got to be good to
not be bad at acting
trying to think of a rapper we can think
about that think about rap think about
hip-hop right you got to be somewhat
good to not be bad
so if you're saying that michael b
jordan is not bad
then then he has to have some sort of
some sort of skill
yeah he's he's he's um
likeable he's got appeal almost like you
think of the rock
early on early on acting you would watch
the rock movies because the rock was in
him yes
and i think michael b jordan is there
now where he's like such a star
women love him and he said something
about the movies the rock was also
playing a certain type of role he was
like i just watched
i just watched the new uh michael b
jordan movie on amazon that [ __ ] was ass
juice but i watched it because he was in
it
you don't like the movie i thought it
was [ __ ] it's a mid man with lots of
seeds in it
the acting was kind of medium and then
they killed lauren london like off the
rip
i was like damn well i mean for those of
you who haven't watched it
you know shade in that [ __ ] very
little yeah
i was like damn it's kind of quiet i
thought it was cool but i'm a fan of
that y'all play call of duty a lot so i
like that kind of [ __ ] yeah
so uh you you say one of the things you
live by is be undeniable be undeniable
which is something you've always said
what do you mean by that i mean by being
undeniable in your talent your skill set
your craft whatever it is that you do
you got to be un you got to make people
the the secret sauce that i believe one
of the secret sauces to my success
is i just didn't go away same with you
right if you just stay
the course and you don't and you and you
continually hone in on your crap i feel
like you're gonna win
you don't have to be the best right like
what you just said about michael b
jordan right
yeah if you undeniably are diligent or
if you're under like if did your girl
[ __ ] with you the first time she met you
of course not that's what i'm talking
about but you are undeniably diligent
and now you're married
that's facts that's it be undeniable
bring value don't take your personal
other thing that you're big on is that
i'm big on as well is the entitlement
thing i hate
entitlement yeah it's crazy because
especially in this business
now man it's the worst these artists
this is something i remember talking to
uh
i think just blaze was talking about
this on clubhouse one day
and how people have direct access to all
these people that you would never in
life have access to
and they just feel entitled to your time
or oh i'm gonna send you this record
right like what does that mean you're
gonna sit so when i tell artists like
don't be entitled it's like
you wouldn't walk up to a girl and just
say give me some [ __ ] um you know what
i'm saying that's what you say to a dj
when you just walk up and be like
here's my song play it right like you
didn't try to like build with me first
like yeah yeah
that's how i feel like that that that's
entitlement and that i hate that [ __ ]
it's like when people dm you like man
you ain't [ __ ] with me kev like yo
here
like bro i don't even know who the [ __ ]
you are bro yo you know
yo the worst part is when someone hits
you with that in your dms and they don't
even follow you
[Laughter]
like fam you don't even follow me yo you
don't even [ __ ] with me enough to follow
me and you're gonna hit me up trying to
get on my podcast to come to a free like
who the [ __ ] are you
i remember uh somebody went on a
campaign and i'm not gonna talk about
who it is here but if somebody in l.a
went on a campaign about how dj head
don't [ __ ] with him
i don't remember him bro i don't
remember meeting this man ever
right so he went on a whole campaign and
was tweeting
dming like the whole stories putting
stories up at me and everything
i think i saw that and so i ended up
hitting one of my big homies and had me
get in touch with him
directly and got on the phone with him
like yo bro what's the problem like i
don't remember you like this is how this
business actually works it's also not
your job to to know everyone
bro i don't know you that's what i'm
saying so it was just one of them type
of things where like
i can't do that kind of thing all the
time but i felt like i wanted to i felt
like it was a teachable moment and in
those moments i'll take the time to
educate
now considering like your position in la
is it it's obviously more of a gift than
a curse but there has to be
some downside to being the guy who's mr
west coast to where almost
i'm i'm assuming most la rappers like i
go through this in arizona where like
[ __ ] will like take it personal
yeah that i don't know who they are
and or openly support their music yeah
and it it it a lot of times it's i just
don't like your music
which is okay that's fine right like i'm
allowed to not
like your might be a good dude and i'm
not but
just because i'm not [ __ ] with your
[ __ ] don't mean like i don't [ __ ] with
you yeah i don't know you yeah
that probably happens a lot with you it
happens and i
i what i try to do is defuse the
situation because i i can't my
in like like i was talking to whack
about this one day right and he gave me
some real bars about
like wax whack people think he crazy
he's not correct smart smartest
he's so intellectually inclined facts so
anyway a little crazy but smart no
definitely nuts yeah nuts but he's smart
as [ __ ]
but he's smart so he was telling me like
different things he was like yeah don't
worry about this do this do this and i
and i was thinking about he said you
know what
it's good that you are level-headed
because you can misuse your influence
and your power
for negativity but you don't you know
you really so what i do is in that
scenario i try to take the time and
defuse
and de-escalate the situation because i
know that i'm so close
to so many different people that it can
go bad real fast right and the
entitlement
comes into play because they like you
said they think that i'm supposed to
know them or remember them from 10 years
ago
or whatever the case and it's not even
personal i don't remember what [ __ ] i
did yesterday right i hit you
today to remember like oh i'm coming
here today right
you know what i'm saying like i don't
remember [ __ ] so when you say like the
arizona [ __ ]
and then also the la [ __ ] i think it's a
little different though because our
politics is [ __ ] up oh yeah
yeah yeah here it's all you know there's
the gang [ __ ] there's the
big homie [ __ ] there's bro our politics
[ __ ] is different
and me looking like like there's not a
lot like if we've been candid
there's not a lot of black people in our
medium in la
right so there's me big boy you got nick
chatting and
chuck yeah pretty much to make up the
bulk of it right yeah
i'm the most accessible one facts
so me so me being accessible in that way
it's like
everybody feels entitled to oh come to
the studio or you
you so-and-so's little homie you gonna
play you wanna look out for this or do
that it's like bro like it don't work
like that
and so trying to explain the industry
aside from the politics
is a complete headache oh it's the worst
yo man play my [ __ ] on the radio like
bro that ain't how this [ __ ] works
bro like fam you got 1100 followers
the last thing you need to worry about
is getting your [ __ ] played on the radio
you'd be worried about getting
anyone to care about you first bro go to
the dsps bro get your [ __ ] pop and get
your numbers up and then everybody else
will follow suit
you mentioned the politics thing um
the new wave of la rappers that you've
been behind from
you know to start the ruchi's and all
these guys it seems as if the politics
don't play into
as much as the older generation a lot of
these younger kids are working together
they don't it do
it does it's still some but it's amongst
them so
it doesn't reach the the media because
it's still amongst that
you'll see like one take jay working
with me it feels like most people i
don't know
yeah the scene yeah the scene okay the
senior for sure they all because they
all went to school together they all
played sports together et cetera so like
and loki most of them are shout out to
tk baron because that's what i got
everybody song shout out to t.k our
baron is crazy
but they what i remember talking to um
kailyn about this [ __ ] and he was saying
that they just learned from the mistakes
of the people that came before them and
it's like oh well if we could do this
[ __ ] together
like ruchi and chike are known for doing
[ __ ] together right
so you might see a a z show but then you
might see roots you pull up you're gonna
see the one take boys there
or vice versa and i think that that's a
beautiful thing
but it gets a little tricky when you
start involving
the homies and hang arounds and
entourages and [ __ ] like that
but for the most part i really commend
the newer generation for being able to
do that
and and also a big big shout out to
draco too
i really i really like what draco the
ruler has done because he came
home and immediately started giving
verses to everybody who would take him
and i felt like that was a big move
especially being in his situation with
the drake record like he don't
necessarily have to do that right but
a lot of those people that he came and
was like he didn't bless him because i
don't want to say like he's demeaning
them but
i felt like what he was doing he made it
his point to come home he's like no i'm
gonna
i'm gonna give this [ __ ] away to
everybody who wanted is it safe to say
he's the hottest rapper in l.a and
blast's the hottest artist in l.a
this get tricky uh no
no no no no listen i'm not going to say
that because guess what if roddy rich
i'm not excluding a global superstar
like roddy
okay and excluding kendrick lamar and
excluding
all i mean i'm talking about hot in the
streets of l.a
i mean you got a lot of people that's
hot in the street no i know but is
anybody hotter than draco
i don't know i'm not in the streets
independently got the drake feature
that's true cleared [ __ ] he got that
yeah but that's that's that's
that's also drake being drake yeah like
oh this guy's name is draco i mean i
think he [ __ ] with i mean draco's music
is
no i'm saying drake is one of the
smartest people to ever be 100
so i understand the way he moves and
what he does and why he does it so
i'm not going to say that that's 100
because of the drake
[ __ ] because the drake knows what he's
doing drake knows who to tap into
he knows what he's doing like that's not
by accident drake don't do anything by
accident right
um i don't know who's the hottest but if
i
if i'm gonna bet my money on people it's
it's a few people i bet them for sure
blast you were you were the first guy
you did
what year did you try to sign blast was
2018 2017 2018 i think
some [ __ ] like that yeah shout out to
blast man you ain't
blast is the guy bro he's the guy he's
the guy
yeah you know i got a i got a text from
from from the homie terrace martin
and he said you were right blast is the
one and i was like i
i knew it i [ __ ] knew because it's
like it's one thing to get to
get the streets it's one thing to be hot
in the industry but when you get
musicians
to be like oh this guy is [ __ ] fire
that's that's a different level to me
yeah i think uh you know the lac and it
seems like it's in a
as good of a place as it's been you know
i would like to see more integration
though
meaning nationally oh yeah yeah i would
like to see like
i know sweetie's from california but she
she's comes off like a national artist
so for her to have draco on her [ __ ]
you know i thought that was kind of dope
i like to see like i love how dave east
comes and taps in with
people out here like i want to see more
of that type of [ __ ] yeah now dave
pulls up and is full i want to see like
rod wave like [ __ ] with like
one take jay right or some [ __ ] like you
know more [ __ ] like that i mean shout
out to quavo he did the blue bucks clan
record yeah
um really you know who i really really
[ __ ] with not from la but i love fredo
bang bro
oh foreign i remember you putting me up
on fredo like i love fredo
he's a good kid man he's a good dude
yeah the top record is crazy
he caught one finally like a like a
radio ranger a real
record idk got a fire ass on him [ __ ] is
hard
that [ __ ] i had to get him on the phone
like bro you actually have a record
that's playable yeah idk's
going crazy uh yeah i think that um but
i do think that the la scene it feels
just like
you know because i think back in the day
when you were coming up with glasses
oh man there was an extreme disdain
towards what the you know back then you
had to get the draco sign or the
whoever cosign right unless you were the
game
right because the game was kind of just
the face of la hip-hop
nationally not saying that in the
streets j-rock and glasses and nipsey
weren't doing their thing
but i remember having conversations with
nipsey even like interviewing him and
[ __ ] where he was not happy with dr dre
a lot of people weren't yeah but that
but i think that's entitlement though
because i had that conversation with
glasses recently because the whole like
new west movement that we established
coming up right and that's like glasses
bishop lamont
right all everybody crook like it was a
bunch of people that was part of that
movement
everybody was coming up had a disdain
for the old guard
the cube the dre snoop etc but i
remember
having a conversation with g about it
and he was saying that it was a sense of
entitlement because
he was like they not [ __ ] with us but
technically we never
asked him for anything they just thought
that they should be paying attention
just like hey like you said like you if
they
if no one's asking why is it assumed
that they gotta [ __ ] with you they yeah
yeah and then i remember
um um i remember glasses we went to a
video shoot it was
i think it was a video shoot for 40. and
we went to the video shooting him having
a conversation with snoop in his trailer
and snoop was like you know that's my
bad like we wasn't playing team ball
but i'ma fix that and then ever since
then everybody's been good
that's i mean it feels it feels good
right now i love
i love snoop too i feel like what snoop
does is unmatched in hip-hop
i think snoop dogg is probably
the most famous rapper ever of course he
is yeah
i don't think that's not even close i
don't even i don't think it's close
i don't even think drake is close to
that level of fame no like
everyone knows who snoop dogg is
everybody grandmas know who snoop is
he's a [ __ ] cultural icon like he
doesn't have to have any more music ever
ever and he's getting bags doing just
being snoop just being snoopy hosting
triller
snoop snoop i think snoop is that's
really by the way i just gotta say
love their performance the sweetie
performance was the worst thing i've
ever seen on tv
i didn't see it oh my god i didn't see
it
that [ __ ] was horrible what was so bad
about it
she lip synced the whole thing and then
she
it was like all choreography and it was
like she don't know how to dance
that's crazy her performance at bet was
fire
i've seen her do her thing yeah whatever
happened at triller
maybe she was maybe she had strep throat
or something dawg that [ __ ] was rough
shout out to sweetie anyway what were
you saying we're talking about the the
snoop thing no i just feel like snoop is
just what he does
even embracing the youth like i feel
like him him and he 40 do an amazing job
at embracing
40 for sure yeah the youth and i think
that's been pivotal in their
longevity i think it's very hard to say
the other thing too is i think if you're
snooping you're e40
you're probably very um who the [ __ ] is
gonna say no
to that nobody like if e40 calls you and
it's like yo get on my album
you're not gonna say no because then you
look crazy
i've heard i've heard a story of a
rapper who blew a shot with 40.
but like like just did not get in the
verse back or some [ __ ] like like what
are you doing what [ __ ] says no
like maybe drake nah he might
nah but nah
drake not turning down you think drake
would say no to snoop or 40
maybe [ __ ] no drake could be out of his
rabbit ass smile i'll tell him
then he 40 need to get that drake first
if you know anything he's going to say
no you might as well keep going drake
not saying no to e40 or snoop dogg
i hope not i mean i mean [ __ ] how could
he be the only one
maybe maybe hove or andre not saying no
103 000 might say no yeah but that's
different
three stacks don't rap i'm saying
yeah he don't even rap like okay so
you're uh
this the the jay-z and nipsey song that
came out oh man
so you're you have co-production credit
on that song yes so how did that happen
i was in the studio
um like i'm always in the studio working
with uh rants
mars 1500 or nothing and ranch was like
yo we got this record like you know
what you want to do i want you to do
some [ __ ] on it i'm like what you want
me to do
like just do your dj head [ __ ] whatever
that means
so i was like all right so he plays me
the song and he's playing me the nipsy
vocals
over the beat right and i'm like oh snip
record like
[ __ ] yeah let's do it i didn't know
nothing about hove right at that time
they were like we're doing something
really special with the record they just
couldn't tell me
right so he's like look just just do
some cuts on the song you know
do some ins and outs some little
scratches whatever i'm like all right
bet
so i did i actually uh recorded it and
and then i turn it in and i ain't i've i
didn't think none of it i was like oh
they must not have used it
i didn't know that it was a bigger play
like later on you know what i'm saying
obviously that's how the music business
work so when they were when it came time
to release the record
it was like oh this is the record and
then once it came
obviously i had it early and [ __ ] right
right um
but we couldn't talk about it because it
was like a part of a rollout
i'm like damn this is crazy but i didn't
know that they were going to actually
give me
credit on this like you know how like
you're producing right right right but
you might not get
you might not get visual credit on the
out on this on the record
so that was like a big deal for me that
was a huge
deal for me especially seeing like
jay-z's name
c and then i'm like right there that
[ __ ] was crazy
so when this song came comes out right
oh [ __ ]
so
you know when we were doing the night
show together yes
uh we really didn't care
to have songs first
no that's not my game it was just really
like no one cares
yeah everybody gets the record at 9 pm
like it's it's uh
not 2009 sure or even 2013 or
it's like yo fam like now
like you said you had the record for a
long time you know
i mean you got yeah you guys in the
studio right this is before the whole
vocals
so the la leakers
shout out to justin shout out to sour
milk um
sour milk well we were you someone when
we were doing the show together or you
talked about recently i'm recently
okay this is after you and i were not on
the air this is
this is uh this is a recent recently
when the song came out right what was
this december january when the record i
don't remember
i think i said i have a bad memory so
the leakers get the song and they're
going crazy
before nine o'clock obviously right
mm-hmm
which has happened a lot cool
sour milk goes on twitter
and says essentially
does anybody want to tell them that we
have we've been going crazy on this
however
long i i don't remember the specifics of
the two well i tweeted i tweeted first
and i said
i'm i'm i'm probably i'm playing this at
nine o'clock
right and then he retweeted yeah it was
just
yeah you said yo we're going crazy at
nine yeah i'm just promoting my show
right you're promoting your show which
is what you should do
right you weren't saying anything about
anybody i don't ever do that right
he retweets it and pretty much says
does anyone want to tell i i don't
remember but we've been going crazy on
this the last two hours bob
i i know that it got interesting
uh because
i don't remember at what point in time
you replied with the credentials of the
song that they were playing and there
was some back and forth
that you have publishing on that you
produced
and you thank them for playing it for
you because you have
production credit on the song now
from a strict perspective of someone
who's just
on twitter and i [ __ ] with
those guys you know they're cool like i
got no problems with them dudes like
you know uh me and justin are cool you
know i just saw justin uh
around the grammys and we you know we're
cool but i'll be
damned if i have never seen anyone
take a worst l on from a radio
perspective
on social media than that that was
[Music]
rough
and then everyone just like
it went crazy yeah i didn't expect i
didn't know
and then and then letty chimed in she
you know obviously she's married to
nipsey's uh
manager shout out to jorge george uh
and and and put her two cents in on it
about hey
it just it got out of hand
and and i don't mean like out of hand
like you didn't
you just literally was awesome like hey
thanks for supporting
by the way uh you might want to check
the credentials on that record
you had it so what happened with that
um that's that's exactly how we have
some back and forth
um and then he he said something it got
kind of like
it started to get to me it started to
get aggressive
on his behalf yeah not on your behalf
yeah so i was just like it's not in your
nature
no i'm i can't play like that this [ __ ]
is like again people take this radio
[ __ ] so serious it's like fam
this is for anyone not not for anyone in
particular
you work for a company that owns a brand
that you don't own listen man
calm down i just what i did was i just i
got swung on and i swung back
you swung back all right you swung back
then you pulled up at their mama's house
and in monte carlo you rolled the window
down and put a uzi out lit that whole
[ __ ] up that's just what i'm
i was taught that you don't start it you
finish it that's what my grandma always
said that's my family that's how we get
out so
i don't ever start anything i don't talk
tough i don't aggressive i don't even
sub people
i just promote my show yes so the
subliminal thing and that's my thing is
like
i've been a part of radio beefs in the
past
uh but i just kind of started to realize
like
any hey it's stupid as [ __ ] because
we're gonna have to see each other
and the way i carry myself is
you you go see me i'm gonna reply to you
on social media because i ain't a social
you know i'm we're going to run into
each other and then we'll have to have
this conversation face to face
and that's happened a few times where
i've had to
run up in vegas shout out to john moog
from kouc
who thought he could talk out the side
of his [ __ ] face and i wouldn't go
[ __ ] walk up to his ass right at the
lowrider show and be like what's up
[ __ ] what you trying to do
this nigga's crazy you know what i'm
saying but what i'm saying
but what i'm saying is is like you know
you and i
never like that's just not what we do no
i don't play
i don't play the bank the radio band
game just because i'm not allowed the
luxury to fake beef with people
and that's something i had i had a
conversation with my superiors before
like i can't
fake beef with people because my lineage
and my my
my environment and my people don't allow
me that luxury to
to like oh let's be for less you know
like it's just
my [ __ ] different and that's why i had
to tell them like i'm not
i always tell people like i'm not a
radio naked like i'm a [ __ ] who do
radio
so it's my [ __ ] different i can't play
like that
so that's why everything i do is a very
articulate approach
i'm never aggressive it's like hey so
when i when i did that it's like
i got swung on and i swung back that's
it
so what what i know that you went you
and milk talked after that yeah we
yeah um og got us on the phone well one
of
one of my og shot the fuzz he hit me was
like you know i need you to you know
talk to him you know like i
don't like this [ __ ] right and so um i
told fuzz
fuzzy's like i'll do anything for fuzzy
right and i told him now i
fuzzy i'll do anything for you so put
him on the phone
so we got on the phone we talked for
like half an hour or something like that
and i don't want to you know just get
all the details yeah but
everything's cool as far as i'm
concerned i let it go right
now that was after i i did go on the air
with it
to be honest oh you should have yeah but
i'm a firm believer in utilizing your
platform
so i'm a friend i get i went on the air
with it the next day and
turned the music off and went in for
about two minutes as you should have
though very
very articulate i didn't call anybody
name i addressed people by name
but i did i remember hearing it i didn't
say anything disrespectful i just
addressed the issue owned up to my
to my antics as well and then kept it
pushing
it kind of felt like uh the moment
wasn't as
much about nipsey as it was about so who
the [ __ ] has got the song first yeah
i just felt like the moment got taken
away from what it was about and everyone
who knows knows that nip
always wanted to work with hove of
course so i felt like that was the
moment
and that moment was robbed when it got
made about radio politics
so that i didn't i didn't like that yeah
for people who don't
like who who kind of see uh radio
from the outside looking in like
i would venture to say you don't have a
lot of relationships across the street
at bottom 106.
i think we're all cool with gabe c right
um but like
is it really that's like i'm not talking
about this particular situation but like
for people who
are watching this it's really not like
that like you'll see
i've seen eman a million like you know
what i mean like and mind you i don't
work for anybody now i don't see nobody
because i'm usually in the streets
but i just mean in general like it ain't
some like everyone thinks it's like some
weirdo like gang [ __ ]
some people approach it that way but for
the most part we're all just trying to
get a [ __ ] bag
and you know we're doing i'm doing me
you doing you
i just listen i'll stay out the way i'm
my what i do is i mind my business i
learned that from the homies and
coming i've been i'm just i was always
the square right all the street dudes
right and they would say look cuz mind
your business
that's what i do i stay in my lane i
don't talk to nobody i don't
flick it up i don't fake beef i don't do
that [ __ ] i just mind my business
hey what up man how to interrupt the
bootleg cab podcast to tell you
about our good friends at odd socks all
right yo
shout out to them for sponsoring the
podcast but also we're being
such a fire company and they just
introduced
their draws that's right
odd socks now got your boxer briefs on
deck
some tapatio joints and then of course
they got the best socks in the game
look at these stone cold socks look at
these two i mean look
i love froot loops but i love these
froot loop socks these are fire i'm
taking those for myself
uh they got all the licenses breaking
bad mac dre
odb wwe street fighter whatever you want
they got
including these draws i love these
drawers i got some on right now
so listen tap in with odd socks go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg kev and you will
save 20
off at checkout so oddsoxofficial.com
keyword bootleg kev
save 20 at checkout thank me later uh
so when we were on the air together we
were on the air for
when did we first get on with this 2018
three years i think
so it was close to three years yeah um
we had some pretty crazy viral moments
oh man
yo do you remember i was just talking
about like do you remember with little
kim
yeah little kim was not [ __ ] with me
she was not [ __ ] with you
she was not [ __ ]
yo lil kim was [ __ ] hot she
was not [ __ ] with you bro yeah
and i was thinking about that i was like
i wonder i wonder like if people
like do people ever get over that [ __ ]
you've been in radio longer than me like
when people have a problem with you
check this out do they ever get over it
i think so because soulja boy came up
here
the other day and theo calls me first
right and he's like
hey man did you say something about
soulja boy in an interview
and i was like probably and he was like
because he he's like yo that's the white
boy used to be on the air with the black
dude
yeah he said some [ __ ] about me in an
interview and i was like oh i don't
doubt it
yeah he came up remember he came on our
show no no but
after that i think and i've put up a
clip of
the only thing i could find by googling
blue light kev soldier boy
was our interview with him and then like
me and draco talking about the big draco
thing dracula ruler
and so i was like it might have been
this but i don't [ __ ] know
and i was like he was like it's all good
but just know he's he's not [ __ ] with
you like that i was like i don't give a
[ __ ] i don't need to be friends with
anybody
soulja boy comes [ __ ] awesome
hangs out with my son we smoke weed
we're hanging out like
[ __ ] it was great like literally
couldn't have went better yeah and so
yeah like and look at the end of the day
sometimes we just gotta do our job no i
agree and you and i wouldn't even do the
kind of [ __ ] like
like we wouldn't chase it we wouldn't
chase the got you moments
no no the only thing that the only thing
that stood out to me
was obviously the gate situation the
kevin gates situation was wild
but in you know and i'm not making a
defense for him it was his first
interview he just got out of his prison
he just got out
let me tell you something what people
don't realize is that
was a lot i had to deal with a lot yeah
a lot of people felt some type of way a
lot of people still feel some type of
way
but kevin gates comes to the radio
station
i go down to the lobby to grab him
and i've i've met kevin gates before but
he doesn't remember obviously
i'm like hey what's up boo like kev he's
like oh that's a good name kevin no well
you know
we both got the same name right shout
out to uh
our guy from atlanta who's with him
dwight come up the elevator
he comes in and he's like he needs the
room to pray yeah
so our guy eric fisher is stuck in the
room
with kevin gates while he's praying for
like 30 minutes
so eric's just sitting there and kevin
gates is in there alone praying
you know because he's muslim so he's
praying right
so i was like oh that's different we've
never had anyone come in and pray before
the interview like
okay whatever whatever floats your boat
or find your lost remote
whatever you gotta do bro yeah shout out
to allah you know what i'm saying
so we come in and do the interview and
automatically
he was just not into the interview no
at all at all he was not [ __ ] with us
whatsoever you he he don't want to be
there and sometimes
we'll do those interviews where it's
like man this will even want to be here
like why the [ __ ] like by the way
artists if you're going to go do a
[ __ ] interview like
and you don't want to do it don't do it
don't don't come because otherwise
anyway so then the moment happens where
you you touched his arm and yo don't
touch me
i feel like i'm being interrogated and
i'm just like bro it's an interview
an interview we asked questions he said
yo hello we got to do this i feel like
i'm being interrogated
right so whatever the case is the
interview finishes
and we wow
awkward bro so look this was interesting
about that
um you wasn't there because you know i
would go to the radio station early
right i just so happened to catch a
couple of people
from his camp at the radio station the
following day
i mean after after we after we put out
the interview right it's it's up
it's gone it's viral i didn't like the
fact we dropped it that way they didn't
like that we put we kept it
we we don't edit our [ __ ] the [ __ ] we're
supposed to do right so
i caught uh a representative in here not
going to say his name
i called a representative of his coming
in in the hallway at the right i'm like
yo what's up what are you doing here
yo man i just i'm trying to see if we
can get the interview taken down
dwight i don't that sounds like dwight
oh
i'm like yo i'm like listen bro we not
taking nothing down
yeah it's too late like it's gone it's
it's i don't i'm not finna start my
my because it's like one of our first
interviews i'm not gonna start my radio
career
editing interviews and taking [ __ ] out
and taking [ __ ] down
they wouldn't ask the breakfast club to
do that so i'm like no so
it's like well you know we just holler
that at your boss see if we can i'll say
all right bet
so i go right into our boss office i sit
down i'm like listen
i know they was he's like yeah they want
to take the interview down i said listen
bro i'm gonna be all the way hunting
with you
i'm i don't he's like well how do you
feel about it i don't want to take it
down
i said furthermore i'll be honest with
you if this is what we're going to be
doing like
doing the politics i'd rather not do
interviews moving forward
and he was like leave it up there so i
respect and it already went viral i
respect that though because
allowing your people to have input on
decisions like that shout out to doc doc
was always like that always like that
but
they were so embarrassed by how that
[ __ ] went
because it was his first interview you
know what i'm saying but i'm like bro
it's
already up it's out and also the crazy
thing about it
is when the interview finished
he hung out with us for like an hour and
a half and played us his new album and
literally said
man i wish we would have started the
interview now because i [ __ ] with y'all
now
bro i [ __ ] you not kevin gates after
that interview stayed at the radio
station
for a long ass time at least an hour
hanging out playing
uh music for us and [ __ ] yeah it wasn't
weird or nothing it was like as soon as
the camera came on
it was weird so it was a lot of backlash
we did have one interview we had to take
down which one
oh uh tiana trump yeah we did it
yeah so we had an interview with tiana
trump that went
viral as [ __ ] that was amazing that [ __ ]
was booming on twitter
there's like twitter clips that got like
6 million views on that that was an
amazing interview
we had this crazy ass interview with
tiana trump and vicki chase yo
i forgot i still got the clip in my
archive
and right around that time we had like a
ratings meeting with our boss he was
like
yo y'all's ratings with females is in
the [ __ ] right now
so then we put out this [ __ ]
interview with these two porn stars
where they're talking
crazy yo i've still got the clue i think
the interview is
on pornhub i still got that one clip in
my phone right now
and they were talking crazy
yo and then well they took it down
yeah yeah that one that one was a little
raunchy but it was fire that [ __ ] was
fire
yo that was one of my favorite that was
one of my
favorite that [ __ ] was fire
yo me and head were just like because
they were just talking amongst each
other
look at each other
what the [ __ ] is going on over yo that
[ __ ]
was wild yo look let me play you this
i got this [ __ ] in my thing in my phone
right now all right i'ma play the audio
for your podcast but bro
when i tell you here's the clip it's got
it ready to go
nah i had to pull it up look
thing before i would just say it was
crazy just because it was so many
different like at the end
or when they needed to come it was so
many types of different
[ __ ] on my face like there was like the
the like
thick that comes and then there was like
the super watery combs and
they were and like all of it was in my
mouth and [ __ ] and i had a swell like
you're like
the craziest one i would say i've done
is with a bella and they shoved a bunch
of gummy bears up her ass
and then [ __ ] her and they all melted
and she [ __ ] him in my mouth wait
what's your best
hey you know you know what in all
honesty we should have been fired for
this
that [ __ ] was why if i'm being honest we
put this on the radio station west
i heart radios instagram i remember dj o
hit us like yo what the
[ __ ] are y'all doing over there yo hey
i ain't gonna lie that's one of the
moments where i was like yeah we
probably out of here
you know
we should not have done that
that was a rough uh that was crazy that
wasn't right i'm glad they kept us after
that
to be honest cheers yeah then there was
uh
the other time we took something down
was uh we did a pop smoke interview and
he hit me directly and asked to take the
interview down yep
yeah that pop smoke interview was
interesting
um people still hit me up about that
yeah there's like there's clips of it
because it was up for like three days
and
you know people ripped it and [ __ ] but
he was just like man
i think i still have the text he just
like no he called me
he was like yo kev man look i don't like
i don't like that interview i feel like
i could have gave you a better interview
i'm gonna be back in like a month we
could do it better
and i want to say that was the trip he
ended up passing away yep
so we took the interview down and uh
yeah people we talked about it though
after like should we just drop it but
like out of respect
like nah yeah i mean a lot of the
interviews out there
on like his fan pages and stuff uh but
yeah i think we were
the first outside of maybe drewski
to interview pop smoke yeah yep like
we're the first major platform to
interview him yeah
no i think i think and it's it's crazy
to to to see what his album
actually ended up becoming because i
didn't expect his album to be like that
at
all i thought it was gonna be all the
order out real [ __ ] yeah and it ended up
being like fire i was like damn i wish
he was here for this
it just it you know yeah man it's crazy
yeah i think that uh
we have some good moments man i think
that uh you know i
i i think for sure like what we were
doing
made everyone else step their [ __ ] up oh
for sure
period for sure i also think that when
you look at
the way radio the way radio was done
is so like antiquated and old school
like the way people were doing it in
comparison to how we started doing our
[ __ ]
it was more like we don't really care
about the fluff there's no like gloss on
this [ __ ]
right it's just some raw radio [ __ ] and
i felt like
the breakfast club obviously kicked in
the door when it comes to that that lane
of course of course
but i felt like we were almost taking a
podcast approach to radio
whereas it was like we were just having
conversations and then whatever we got
from that conversation
we would truncate it down and that would
be the radio show right right yeah and
then uh
i just had a [ __ ] thought and it just
went away
god damn it i just had a good thought
about something we did
i don't remember well another thought
that i had too is we have a lot of
moments in history
as far as like oh yeah not even the
viral [ __ ] but i'm getting tagged and
[ __ ] where it's like
i'm talking about like bro we did we did
the nipsey passing
dude that was crazy because that was i
was on the air sundays
check this out the sunday nipsey died
nifty died on a sunday kobe died on a
sunday yep that i was on the air for
both of those yep
then you came into my shift and we ended
up doing the nipsey thing yep
that was rough rough bro i think that
was probably the roughest
uh you know obviously kobe dine was
rough but we knew nip you know
uh that was the roughest [ __ ] was to
do that radio show that was rough
and all i could think about and then we
also
you knew because we were on almost right
away
yeah and you i think you had information
that it wasn't looking good but
while we were on the air we couldn't
divulge that yeah i couldn't talk about
it yet so we were waiting for it to come
down that it was official that he passed
and then
yeah one of my homies one of my homies
one of my street homies hit me was like
yes
it's a wrap bro like i just want you to
be the first to know because you know
that he [ __ ] with you tough so
i was like what like so then um doc hit
me and was like yo you mind going to the
station i'm like bro
i don't know what to say right and he
was like just be honest
just talk so i went up there and came up
there and we did the show
that was like one of them and all i
could think about is
is those old school radio moments where
i remember being
i remember being at i remember being on
my way to school
when 9 11 happened yeah yeah and i
remember big boy being on the air that
morning
right and he just stayed on the air like
the whole time and he was just like yo
if you go outside and look up there's no
planes in the sky in the country
and i was like i remember i literally
remember that and i was like this is one
of them things where people are going to
be remembering this [ __ ]
and it it and i thought about this after
the fact obviously i'm not thinking
about that while we're doing the show
but i'm thinking about this after the
fact like people have been with us for
moments
that probably they're going to remember
for the rest of their life
and that [ __ ] is that's the [ __ ] to me
that is like
yeah it's crazy that's fire kobe's death
was
so big in the world but i don't feel
like
it the impact it felt like here
i feel like nipsy [ __ ] felt way crazy
well it was it
because i think what happened was like
uh nemesis was murdered
yeah i think it's the like colby's death
was horrible
and tragic it was horrible accident yeah
but the way nipsey died man
we saw it ever in broad daylight like it
was just a
complete blazing act of like murder
you know what i'm saying so it's like
that to me
is like something because and also you
gotta look at what he or he what he
represented
yeah it's not even what he did or who he
was nobody give a [ __ ]
what you represent is like everything
and if you represent hope
you represent community you represent
you know aspiration entrepreneurship
giving back whatever it is you represent
and then some and then you that
that type of thing happened to you where
it happened to them i think it quit it
makes everybody question their own
mortality and i think that's what
that's that [ __ ] that shakes everybody
yeah that was rough that one the kobe sh
i was numb for the kobe [ __ ] to be
honest
i didn't even process it till like a
month later yeah the kobe [ __ ]
i was really really sad and i never even
[ __ ] with kobe when he was like i was
i'm a i don't [ __ ] with the lakers i
[ __ ] with him now because lebron's on
there
but growing up i hated kobe right but i
like didn't hate him in like a real way
i just as a sports fan he's a sportsman
but when he died i was like [ __ ] like
this was like a part of my life facts
like i watched this guy play
basketball's entire career
like and now this will gone like
you never know you never know bro that's
that's one of the things to me even
even when pop smooth got murdered like
it was it's like different things that
like
i never thought would be a part of my
radio career yo the fact that we lost
pop smoke x juice world
yup nipsey kobe mac miller
yep all while we were doing the show
yeah is insane i feel like we're
forgetting people
oh for sure a lot of people have been
passing man uh we for sure forgiving
people but i'm just saying though
that i've never thought about like oh
this is going to be a part of my radio
journey
yeah because even with pop smoke like
pop smoke like you know he did a lot of
interviews but he didn't do that many
nah he didn't do a lot of interviews he
didn't do a lot so it's like yo we have
like
you know we talked to him really early
on and he was cool as [ __ ] like he was
always super nice super cool
and he had just so much uh just so much
like more to give
and then also if you look at the other
side of the spectrum when we had ymw
mellie on
he went to jail the next day or the day
after we did the last interview the last
interview before he got locked up yep
yeah it's crazy man there's a lot of
[ __ ] dog i think um
one of my favorites though
one of my favorites probably ever
was t-pain oh the t-pain interview is a
legendary i love
t-pain bro he's so yeah we talking for
like an hour at least
i love t-pain now that t-pain interview
was a movie he's so entertained he's so
honest and funny and we got drunk
drunk whenever we were taking shots yeah
you did and i like 50 cent
50 was dope i love how honest 50 is ross
was dope
well we've had some good ones i mean the
haiti baby freestyle went crazy
bro the haiti baby freestyle bro
yeah you had him on your show i had him
on mine after the fact and i love
the fact that he like he leans into that
like that's part of my legacy
it's the biggest part of his legacy at
this point that's the homie but yeah i
mean right now like with that he's
nothing he's done it's ever been bigger
than that yeah that [ __ ] had rihanna
tweeting that chrissy teigen tweeting
about him and mcmill posted him like
that shit's insane
facts [ __ ] haiti baby shout out to
stockton man
yo the other thing we did on the air
that we weren't crazy about was
something called the celebrity smash
oh man so we had a bit called the
celebrity smash which in theory is an
amazing idea
uh and it was where we had people call
in
and give us stories about times they
[ __ ] celebrities celebrities
and this was our boss doc winters idea
and it and he had tried it with the
breakfast club
and and and the problem was was it it
was a great idea but
to execute it without putting people's
names out there or trying to make it
too obvious that people knew
because at the end of the day you want
listeners to be in on it yeah
yeah so we it got to the point where we
had to edit so much of these calls we
were getting that it was so like
bland and and kind of took away from the
original
appeal of the bit yeah now i think that
i think the celebrity smash will work
in 1998 if you know i think it'll work
now just you have to you have to say who
it is
you got to but the only problem is you
can't do that now because because people
will be
yeah slander and yeah all kind of stuff
bro if you can say who it is it'll work
listen we had some guy call
the first week we did this thing we did
the celebrities
which oh [ __ ] i'm not talking about this
one
yeah yes are you go ahead i'm not going
to say who who who he said
oh okay okay but we had this guy calling
and he told us a story
about 12-minute phone call it's a
12-minute phone call we still got the
call
about this a man who called
and talked about his
sexual relationship with a very
prominent
mogul in hip-hop yes and gave details
details extreme details in which
made it extremely believable with this
guy 100
and when i say it had us like
cause we started that bit and almost
right away we got that call
and we were like oh this [ __ ] about to
be crazy
this [ __ ] about to go crazy yeah all
right we're about to get into so much
trouble and the person in which this guy
put on a blast is someone
who you don't want to [ __ ] with in and i
don't want no smoke
no smoke so
[Laughter]
right so we sent we sent it over to uh
our boss and he's like you got to take
this out take this out take this out
take this out take this out cool
it ended up still being very appealing
on the air
but that bit could have if if it was
like 99
and we were doing that bit and we were
letting these names fly
oh a lot of the people who called it was
just run-of-the-mill groupie [ __ ]
i was in san diego with my girl and i
didn't [ __ ]
whoever the [ __ ] right oh yeah of course
you did of course you did
or but then there was there was some no
there was a couple there was a few
that were kind of crazy kind of crazy
and a lot of it too was because like
these people would be married
or there would there would be some sort
of remember the the family the the girl
from the big family with the nda
yes yeah bro the girl from the big
family with the nda i do remember yeah
yeah and and and mind you who knows
if these people were telling the truth
but we got bro
that call about that mogul was that [ __ ]
was crazy
crazy i still be playing that [ __ ] for
people you do oh yeah i'll be like yo
i don't play it for nobody
in the event this [ __ ] leaked i
destroyed it yeah that was that was a
wild uh
that was a pretty wild wild bit we did
yeah we ended up not doing it because
they just kind of got too watered down
and then
we got in trouble a bunch we stay you
know what i've never been in trouble so
much in my life and doing the show with
you
yeah i mean every time they say yeah i
mean you know
no i don't know [ __ ] stayed in the
principal's office
like [ __ ] what we do ah [ __ ]
he said you know that was a that was a
good time so for people who are watching
this
i think it's important because there's
aspiring radio personalities or people
who think they want to get into radio
who are watching this
and you and i keep having this
discussion about
our business and the future of it and
where it is what would you tell someone
like that who's
got zero radio experience but their
aspiration
is to be a radio personality like us
start just start with your platform now
build it build your platform
don't don't like don't wait for the
people don't
like wait for the right opportunity
don't go begging for a job build your
platform
start off like with your own like blue
leg kev podcast or homegrown radio or
so many other entities that people are
doing you know what i'm saying um
the brilliant joe budden pocket whatever
you want to build build your own [ __ ]
and then take that somewhere to a
platform that might want the content
it's almost like because the old school
way doing [ __ ] as far as like oh i'ma
start as an intern and work my way up
that's cool that shit's almost dead
though but it's almost a
non it's almost non-existent because of
the simple fact the way the industry has
changed
it's almost like you got to already have
some [ __ ] going on especially i mean
obviously we're in la
you know we're speaking from being in
market number two
that's fact so you it so it's it's a lot
harder to
like think of jason from hollywood
unlocked that's true jason from molly
would unlocked
had this huge platform they gave him a
syndication deal at iheart he's got the
weekend show him in damage
they already had some [ __ ] going but i
also say that if you're in
wichita kansas yeah you know what i'm
saying if you're in wichita kansas
start your podcast and take your podcast
to the radio station like this is what i
do i would love to do that here
or whatever the case may be but have
some action items to show people don't
just go in
blind and be like hey i want you know i
want to here's my here's the burden of
training me
how to be a personality yeah i think
that people got to realize this
nowadays uh more than ever
those wichita kansas jobs or those
first of all they don't pay nothing
second of all they're those
those slots are dying
yeah i mean that's what i'm saying i
will say build your platform
you see you gotta be undeniable be
undeniable and radio you gotta be
undeniable if you're gonna cut through
the
bro you have to be undeniable
rowdy rich was a great interview too
yeah roddy was dope
yeah yeah right he's a perfect someone
who's undeniable the undeniable dog
yeah undeniable
well uh and then homegrown radio are you
guys still doing um
like the weekly podcast so you guys
started that
in one year 2010 or 2011 20 we started
doing homegrown yeah
2009. in chuck's apartment and truck's
apartment
and then that turned into now you're
doing nights in la but
over the years that was like a thing
even if you weren't from l.a i remember
just you know i've always been tapped in
with what you do but like just being
like oh that [ __ ] is dope like like you
said like
you had your own thing and whether or
not
you guys would still do it if i heard
never stepped in fact
that's what i'm saying like but we
started doing that and then
it started to it became like just a
regular weirdo hey will you go let my
son in real quick
sorry go ahead we were doing internet
radio show and then it became like
hey let's do a podcast because chuck was
resisting because he needs old school
radio he want the mix show and all that
[ __ ] that we doing podcasts and then
that became what it is now
but i think like you said like if you
just build your [ __ ]
like people will be invested in you like
you say you've been tapped in
if you just build your [ __ ] people will
type in with you yeah out to ireland
it's also like when you see people like
that it's like you you almost run a
route for them you want to see them win
because they've been they've been with
you from the jump
yeah and then and you build your own fan
base
facts so you come in with fanbase you
come in with analytics you come in with
people that want to hear you or see what
you got doing
um you also now are doing something on
big boys neighborhood the head talks
yeah that's going to get me into some
[ __ ] for people who don't know you kind
of originally
started at iheart helping like being a
part of big boy's show now that was
essentially
doing you're answering calls yeah yeah
that's
that's another thing i've never talked
about that the when i when
when they when i got hired at iheart
they hired me for two hours a week
right eventually uh something a position
opened up for me
to basically answer the phones and
screen calls for big boy
i did that for three years and that's
the thing that's what nobody talks about
it's about doing those types of things
it's like
whatever you bring value that's number
two in my thing bring value yeah be
undeniable and then bring value that's
number two whatever room you in
hey pick up a mop you know i'm saying go
get the door you know i'm saying go get
put some waters in the refrigerator
whatever you got to do to bring value to
the situation that's what i did
with big boy and i appreciate that
opportunity i felt like
me running boards and editing audio and
[ __ ] behind the scenes on big boy
allowed me
to get a paid education and how to
produce radio on the highest level
it was almost like you know a lot of
people might be like man [ __ ] this i'm
that's how i feel i really pay but now
but like yo you're getting the real
that's how i felt at first if i'm being
100 honest when i first
first told me about what i would be
doing i was like man i want to be on the
air though
i'm a radio [ __ ] right but silas
was like
get in the room right once you get in
the room it's over get in the room and
bring value
stop worrying about what you're called
when you're in the room and i'll use
that for saying
that same ideology even to this day like
even with women it's like don't worry
about
what we are just be do the job that you
want before you get the title
which is why you're single west coast
this [ __ ] right here
got the craziest woman philosophies but
they're really not even crazy they're
very practical
very practical but unfortunately women
are practical creatures
they're emotional creatures i understand
which is why you're single west coast
i'll be damned it's like you know when
people work at mcdonald's where they
don't eat the food
it's because they know better by the way
mcdonald's is fire
i'm just saying the people who work
there they know yeah they just know
better so that's how i look at it
uh another a person i want to talk about
who's you know someone who's been
instrumental in my career and obviously
in yours is charlemagne you've got a
great relationship with charlemagne as
do i
he's always kind of uh been there
when he didn't need to be for me at all
for me either
i think for i think he did the same
thing for both of us yeah i mean i
remember
um individually though yeah in like 2010
i was in vegas and
i had yellowwolf on the show and yellow
talked bad about him and charlemagne hit
me and was like yo
i'm more than uh i forget what he said
he was like yo but you asked the right
questions in that interview and ever
since then he just tapped in we would
you know dm at each other and then
he shouted me out in vibe magazine in
2012.
and he's just always like he's
the soup like the biggest when we think
of charlemagne like
i i'm so motivated by that man and
inspired by what he does
and in our business it don't get bigger
than him
no right it doesn't get bit like he's in
our field in our field there's not
nothing
bigger than what charlemagne does or
like he's the god and that you know
that's his name but like
i look at him like the god and
for him to still go out of his way to
tap in and help bring up and empower
everybody else yeah bro he just called
me last week and it was one of the best
conversations i i've ever had in my
career
and it was like i came away from like a
15-minute conversation with him
and you know a decade after him and i
first connected and i was like
wow like that [ __ ] meant so much to get
the call i got from him and he don't
have to do that
i'm gonna be all the way transparent
being able to be friends and peers
with charlemagne and big boy because i'm
from la
is like beyond comprehension it's crazy
it's beautiful
big boy i grew up loving big boy it's
beyond comprehensive
yeah the fact that and they give me
props and like like yo this [ __ ] is dope
keep doing that or
put they'll send an email on my behalf
or like that [ __ ]
is wild it's insane even big obviously
is charlemagne is closer to us in age
and and as far as us like we could have
been peers if our careers might have
started five
years later or earlier rather you know
but like
biggs that [ __ ] i think i think
what you said about was charlotte uh
like he
he hit doc up for me too same same here
yeah
to cosign me to get to get the job at
the station
and i think that was big but there was
also like i remember when charlotte used
to come to la with debbie
with debbie brown like back in the day
like 2010
right or some [ __ ] like that and he
would like sleep on our couch and we
didn't know he was just the weird homie
that
she would [ __ ] with from the from new
york we didn't know him like that
but i think like you said i think that's
also what keeps you in the game it's
like what we're saying about snoop and
and 40. bringing people up bringing
people up
i think that that's i'm trying to take
i'm lowkey trying to take his crime his
his crown of being of lead in the league
and assists
i want to throw more assist in him he's
doing a lot man he's throwing a lot of
assists bro
he's [ __ ] john stockton i'm trying to
come for that though
yeah i mean but also it's tougher now
because i feel like
he's throwing us lives but we came from
an era where the entitlement wasn't as
high facts
like it's so hard to find people who are
young who
have the hunger or or even have the work
ethic
that we came up with facts well also we
but that's a survivor's mentality though
we didn't have a resources yeah we had
to we had to
so now you got like you can do [ __ ] on
your phone that we couldn't do
with whole studios you know what i'm
saying like it's insane
it's just a different it's a different
thing and now we sound like the old
heads but it's just
now paid in like you got to be a paid
intern you can't do an unpaid internship
anymore you can't even call them interns
anymore which is insane
you can't you can't call them interns
because there's specific rules
and laws that protect them like i worked
for free
from august of 2005
until october of 2006 before i even got
paid to
set up a [ __ ] tent at the radio
station i was free
before i got paid to be on the street
team yeah it's like that [ __ ] is like i
wouldn't trade it for the world though
bro i would have did at that point like
i remember i remember i went to school
so when i went to radio broadcasting
classes and
radio broadcasting school in 2005 i went
with mondo fresco
me and him yeah me and him went to
school together mondo's the first person
to show me
anything in radio like how to edit on
the back we didn't have computers
at the studio we had like these old like
digit cart things that we had to edit on
so he taught me how to edit [ __ ] like
that and then
he was like i'm gonna go this way i'm
gonna go intern at the
at the radio station i'm like man [ __ ]
that i'm gonna go build some [ __ ] right
and so we kind of we went our separate
ways in that way
he went an intern and worked his way up
and then i went and built my [ __ ] in the
streets
but i think the reason why you and i
had to do what we had to do is because
we chose to to do it our way
so to speak you could have conformed and
probably had an easier route
i feel like the way i did it was
conforming loki at the time that was
just kind of what you did you interned
then you got on the street team
nah then you got on weekends or then you
boarded up then you got on weekends
no but you still always you were always
innovative in your in the way you
approached the internet
yeah yeah yeah well i think early on uh
like that wasn't a thing like that yeah
09 is when i first started
the only other person who was doing what
i was doing was um peter parker
yeah that's what i'm saying that wasn't
a thing like that yeah i would put
phoners on youtube and they'd get posted
by like not right and two dope boys
exactly yeah that was a different
approach to doing radio
yeah i give a lot of that to uh peter
parker
and rosenberg rosenberg is who inspired
me to buy a flip cam
word he me too and so i got the flip cam
and every interview if you ever go
online and you watch like justin bieber
freestyling on my show or
50 cent 50 cent little thing with the
little usb
that [ __ ] bro that [ __ ] was cheap and
like every interview i ever did was on
the flip cam
are you serious yeah when i was in vegas
every interview i did cute kendrick
freestyles [ __ ] j cole freestyles
[ __ ]
50 cent pulled out a half a million
dollars in cash on my show in vegas
and that was all on a flip cam damn how
about you baby joel on the flip cam
holding that [ __ ] yo low-key that flip
cam was crazy
that [ __ ] i remember because i remember
earlier that [ __ ] in your pocket the
only reason i'm tripping out is because
i shot the whole the tour that i went on
with with
j-rock and glasses and kendrick i shot
all that [ __ ] on the flip cam bro that
flip camera that was 2010.
super clutch 2010. well that sucks that
that company didn't like
gopro kind of took their vibe but even
even gopro's less convenient than a
flipkart 100 percent less
usb was built into the camera yeah that
[ __ ] was fire bro
damn damn we old yeah shout out to flip
anyway well look uh anything you guys
got coming up yeah i want a shout out to
um
i want to shout out them to my team
homegrown radio of course we got this
we got some really big brewing um coming
soon i can't really say right now
still attorneys but um be on the lookout
for homegrown radio
followed on all platforms and then uh
what about uh are you gonna try you know
you do a lot of cons
you kind of unofficially help a lot of
artists in the studio and stuff yeah i
don't
i don't do like color the consulting
business i don't i don't charge and [ __ ]
like that i just
i just try to help where i can because i
feel like like like again we
coming up nobody told us nothing nobody
helped us i can't name
one thing outside of big boy and fuzzy
right
i can't tell you on julio g excuse me
big boy fuzzy julio g and dj dents
i can't tell you one thing i learned
from anybody on the radio in l.a
i didn't learn anything like anything
everlasting from anybody
yeah i think the fact that that's why i
use my platforms
with stocks and bitcoin and books
because
outside of those specific people i can't
tell you anything i learned from anybody
that's [ __ ] crazy i've been here my
whole life yeah i mean yeah
radio in la was extremely um i mean the
fact real signed on
and now there's two options yeah it's
great because
that means for me it was so hard for me
to get on it
power 106. i was trying to get hired
there forever bro i applied for every
single opening that ever happened there
and maybe i just wasn't great at the
great
but i was doing my [ __ ] [ __ ] and it
just never
was i was told it was never going to be
a thing for me to
be at power 106. i won't say why but i
was just told like
hey man because you are who you are
you're never going to be on a power
like like jimmy's [ __ ] with you you're
dope
but because you don't check this box in
this box you just won't be on over and
no those boxes are the reasons why i
never applied
and so for me when real signed on you
know my
dream was always to be in la so when
real signed on
i was like thank god there's another
station
like wow and then what's dope about this
station was they didn't care about those
boxes
they were like who's dope who's dope and
i people a lot of people don't know this
i was supposed to do afternoons at real
92 3 when they launched
i was under contract in tampa and i
couldn't get out of my deal but doc
made the offer he was like yo you gotta
you gotta go to your guys
in tampa and they gotta let you out of
your deal i got after news for you
because he was they were going through
the there was also a big damn
but yeah i mean that's why i i really
respect the [ __ ] out of uh
really dude you know in our business
people be giving iheart
a lot of [ __ ] right i mean look at the
end of the day they're like the yankees
they're a major corporation right so
as they go the industry goes and they're
a corporation
so there is situations in which people
get let go
in matt but guess what it just is what
it is
i will say this i heart to me
is still extremely talent driven
and what i appreciated about working for
doc
was nothing mattered
you could be for the most part because
we've worked with some real difficult
[ __ ] right that ended up not
making it
but those people were empowered because
they brought value yeah
and like if you're dope and you're doing
your [ __ ]
that could put you on yeah period he'll
give you opportunity give you an
opportunity for me
and whether or not you run with it like
shout out to a girl dj leslie
ran with it killing it killing it i love
it
murdering it shout out to chuck dizzle
chuck dizzle murdering it got an
opportunity they
gave him an inch he turned it into a
mile now he's on the night show shout
out to dj head
same thing same thing same [ __ ] thing
yeah
for me i had blind faith and doc
left a job in tampa came to l.a
moved to phoenix from tampa drove to la
every saturday doc this was after he had
offered me afternoons and they moved on
because i couldn't get out of my deal so
doc was like look
just get in the building and i'll handle
the rest wow
so i moved from uh oh let's restart that
there we go
so i moved from tampa to phoenix and
drove to [ __ ] la
and did one weekend shift uh
every weekend every remember you was
driving back and forth every saturday
from 10 a.m to 3 p.m i was on the air in
l.a and that was huge
now i was djing friday night getting
done from my club and mobbing straight
to la afterwards paying eric rock to
drive me
and [ __ ] i did that from august to
december and then i was like doc like
some [ __ ] gotta shake out soon you know
what i'm saying like i can't
this [ __ ] is killing me you know and um
[ __ ]
the end of january
leaving parts of the story out like me
like leaving real for like three weeks
and going and doing nights at a
live 105 in phoenix but i
you know he's like hey i got we're
making it happen so just don't sign any
other contract anywhere and then i ended
up doing nights with damage and dre
sinatra yeah
which was you know cool in itself and
shout out to those guys but yeah it was
all
doc again if you're dope
i tell this to anybody anything there's
an opportunity in any situation whatever
opportunity you get you got to make the
most out of it
make the most out of it bro because you
might not get that [ __ ] ever again
ever again bro ever i just told that the
soulja boy too i was like bro you got
nine lives
oh for sure bro that shit's crazy in
fact he caught a record again good for
him
as he should though yeah he was being
built for tick-tock
facts he is he is ahead of his time
there is nobody like he should be the
tick-tock god i gave him his flowers too
i said look bro hey you the guy bro
yeah facts well look dj head go get adam
on uh
instagram and twitter and uh subscribe
on
spotify homegoing radio man homegrown
radio all platforms listen
to the radio morning
a week yeah i think we're doing two i
don't know because we the way we
we do it but i think we're doing two
days a week two days a week three days a
week
three days a week two or three days and
then every night big boy's neighborhood
seven to eleven
on i heart real ninety two three yep
with the chuck dizzle man
yup homegrown radio